you know it just never ceases to amaze
me how much improvement you can create
to your brain
doing fasting but there is a sweet spot
uh you're going to have to fast for at
least 18 hours
and so you'll have an eating window of
six hours
and a fasting span of 18 hours to really
see some major improvements in your
brain so it's not hard you just skip
breakfast first meal is at 12
second meal is at six or it could be
first meal eleven in the morning
second meal at five
or first meal at one o'clock and the
second meal at seven and that means no
snacking during your fasting you can eat
during your eating window but i would
recommend just having two meals one at
lunch one at dinner and
if that's a problem if you're still
hungry
definitely add more fat at the end of
the meal whether it's a big handful of
nuts pecans or or macadamia nuts or some
other types of fat now one of the
reasons i'm doing this video is
simply because there's so much bad
information of what to eat when you get
off the fast if you have
any problem with your brain dementia
add
seizures parkinson's alzheimer's
so let's just dive right in here now you
have
ketones right the benefits of ketones
for your brain and there's other
benefits i want to talk about but
ketones in general are very very
therapeutic to your brain
sometimes you'll hear this argument that
the brain only is can live on sugar or
glucose and
ketosis is dangerous that is completely
absolutely positively not true your
brain prefers ketones if
given the choice between a ketone or a
glucose
molecule as fuel
the brain will choose the ketones over
glucose
there are three ways to make ketones
you can make ketones by going the
ketogenic diet by reducing your carbs
and eating more fat and so some of the
fat you eat will be turning in the
ketones if you keep your carbs low
another way to produce ketones is just
fasting now you're not going to eat
anything so your body will go after your
fat reserve and turn your own fat into
ketones
the benefit of doing fasting
compared to the ketogenic diet is that
you're going to produce a lot more
ketones you'll get deeper into ketosis
and you'll have a lot of other
additional benefits that extend beyond
ketones you'll have certain genes that
will be expressed just merely from the
fact of not eating and creating that
mild stress on the body which then
compensates and produces all these
magical wonderful things to your brain
our bodies our brains have evolved
from
not eating starvation
so we have all sorts of genes that help
us survive when we don't have food i
mean think about way back before we had
the oil can eat buffets
i mean there are days that we didn't eat
and if there wasn't food available
we would die
so what happens is our brain becomes
smarter it becomes more focused it
improves when we don't eat so then we
can find food to eat and a lot of people
will never discover this unless they try
fasting
and then they'll find out wow i feel so
much better your mood your cognitive
function improves
and then they're hooked so our brains
are majorly benefited by ketones
by
gene expression from doing fasting
and when you exercise you will generate
ketones as well and another major
benefit of fasting is that
you are reducing
glucose in the diet
and that alone
greatly reduces the destruction the
oxidation of what glucose does to your
neurons in your brain into your nerve
cells not to mention a lot of other
tissues and so the reality is that
a lot of people have actual damage to
their brains from a high carb diet from
the chronic exposure to glucose because
what glucose does to your neurons is it
destroys your neurons and then your
neurons can no longer
absorb glucose so they can't get fuel
and the fact that the person never goes
on a ketogenic diet or or doesn't lower
their carbs starves them even more
because if you don't lower your carbs
you're dependent on the glucose which
you can't absorb and so the cells can't
get energy or atp so it's really the
lack of the fuel that the neurons
need that destroy
the brain so when you switch over your
fuel source
the neuron finally can get fuel
and ketones bypass this damage and feed
the neurons directly
also the support cells it's called the
glial cells one specifically being an
astrocyte
helps feed the neuron so if you never do
fasting never do the ketogenic diet
unfortunately these cells have a very
difficult time getting fuel
thus all the complications uh that come
with diabetes to the nervous system to
your brain you have diabetic induced
dementia
you have diabetic neuropathy
that that's damage to the nerve cells
because what happens is all this glucose
destroys the the capillaries the blood
flow to the nerves
and so the first nerves that show a
problem are the nerves on the bottom of
your feet that's why you get peripheral
neuropathy like numbness burning on your
feet and then your hands and then it
destroys the capillaries to the eyes
which happen to feed the retina which is
a nerve it's an extension of the brain
that's the term diabetic retinopathy and
then there's one more thing i want to
mention
there's
a part of the nervous system called the
autonomic nervous system okay and when
you have diabetes
which is a high sugar situation or
condition
you could develop something called
diabetic autonomic
neuropathy and that's quite interesting
because a lot of people don't talk about
it but i'm going to go through the
different
conditions
that this can manifest as okay
number one a high pulse rate okay
because the autonomic nervous system
controls the the heart okay you can also
have exercise intolerance
because you can't adapt to it because
the autonomic nervous system is all
about
helping the body adapt to stress and
exercises and stress you also have
another condition called orthostatic
hypotension that's a condition where you
stand up and you
you get dizzy or you could even pass out
a severe condition
of that is called pots and so one of the
remedies at least a temporary remedy is
benfotamine which is a vitamin b1
because b1 greatly
improves the complications of
diabetes uh insulin resistance and
problems with insulin in general but
ultimately if you have orthostatic
hypotension
you need to get off the carbs for sure
and then we have another condition
called gastroparesis which is a
condition of that affects the autonomic
nervous system to the point where
everything moves very very slowly
through your digestive tract okay that
comes from destruction of the autonomic
nervous system another condition would
be constipation because if the nerves
that go to the smooth muscle of your
colon are not working you're not going
to be able to digest and everything is
going to be very sluggish and you have
another condition called esophageal disc
motility which is a fancy term for you
you get regurgitation up into your
esophagus from the stomach or heartburn
acid reflux that type of thing you can
also have chest pain or a feeling that
food is stuck in your throat and you
might have difficulty swallowing all
those conditions can stem from a problem
with your autonomic nervous system
because of the way the blood sugars have
affected that part of the nervous system
but you don't necessarily have to be a
diabetic to have those conditions
because
you could literally be a pre-diabetic or
you could have severe insulin resistance
and have
some of those symptoms as well
the reason i'm bringing that up because
if you have similar symptoms you need to
change your diet but let's just kind of
go through some of the amazing effects
of
fasting on your brain number one it
slows down the age-related
brain decline and brain-related diseases
like alzheimer's parkinson's things like
that so fasting slows down the aging
brain and it helps to reverse damage to
the brain from these other chronic
conditions
fasting also allows the brain cells to
finally get the fuel that it needs if
you have damage from a high carbohydrate
diet fasting reduces inflammation
within your brain fasting stabilizes
your neurons
as in doing the ketogenic diet for
seizures which is a neuron that becomes
out of control so this is why ketones
can help stabilize
the over excitation of a neuron
fasting has certain gene benefits by
expressing certain genes
that help the nerves connect better
fasting increases genes that increase
the repair action
of the neuron fasting will also greatly
boost
antioxidants in certain parts of your
brain
that will help decrease the
complications of some chronic
inflammation or chronic type of brain
problem whether you have alzheimer's
parkinson's or
some type of autoimmune disease of the
brain like ms
so if your body makes more antioxidants
it's called
endogenous antioxidants you can then
reduce the free radical damage that can
occur when you have all this
inflammation fasting will also give you
benefits with something called autophagy
so for example if you have plaquing of
the brain because you have alzheimer's
or you have some type of scar tissue in
your brain or some damaged proteins in
your brain
when you fast you go through this
autophagy and autophagy is basically
recycling these proteins that are
damaged in your brain so it's making
your brain new again fasting can also
greatly improve
structures in the brain like the
structure that controls the circadian
rhythms
that help you sleep and fasting also
greatly improves your mood it'll bring
you up
from either
a depressed state or a state of anxiety
so fasting will affect your mood and
your cognitive function and i'm talking
about your ability to learn
your ability to
focus and be productive
your memory and that includes also
spatial memories so let's say for
example you just parked your car and you
can't quite remember where you parked it
well
fasting can help you locate
yourself in space your gps for example
is going to be off so your internal
ability to locate and navigate
through things especially when you're
driving
gets lost so you basically can improve
your navigation as well as your motor
skills your coordination your balance so
one of the reasons i'm doing this video
is to help put you on the right track to
give you the correct information so you
can optimize your your brain function
because
if you do a search right now for
alzheimer's okay what's going to come up
on the first page of google is a diet
from hopkins university is a diet that
webmd will recommend which is a diet
from the alzheimer's association and
these diets are all the same in fact the
diets are all the same for diabetes
heart disease it's the same old same old
and i'm not kidding i'm gonna i'm gonna
list some of the things that they
recommend for dementia
for heart disease
for diabetes and i'm not kidding at
least three servings of
whole grains every single day okay right
there it's gonna create inflammation
and it's also gonna increase your blood
sugars you don't wanna do grains
with these conditions number two beans
more than three times a week okay all
right whatever beans are high in carbs
that's that's kind of a minor point next
one and this is what hopkins said
less than five pastries or sweets per
week i mean you don't want to do any
sweets okay it's bad advice to even
allow people to consume pastries or
sweets
for dementia or heart disease whatever
next one all right one glass of wine or
another alcoholic
beverage again why are you even
recommending wine or alcohol when
someone has this condition is there any
benefit
in pastries or alcohol or whole grains
for dementia and the answer is no
so
if you're new to my channel and you want
to get on the right diet to optimize
your brain health
you need to watch this video right here
you